how much money is in your bank account
I think four hundred dollars all right
do you have a job where'd you get that
money no I do not how much money is in
your bank account
like 20 bucks
all right uh do you have an occupation
uh Uber driver what's your approximate
salary
um like one to two thousand a week all
right thank you the amount of money that
all those people just said there's no
good or bad amount they're all bad you
need to make more money A and B you need
to spend less of the money and it was
funny because almost all of those were
in like shopping areas and so all of
them are frequencing places to drain
their bank accounts on things that will
not increase the money that they have
and so when you have less money the best
place to put it is in ways to make more
money which is usually going to be
skills in education